on this particular topic of trans issues
is that the reason you were banned from
twitch I'm not sure I don't know uh they
just said hate speech but I don't use
like slurs or anything so it's hard to
know exactly so I think you made the
claim that trans women shouldn't compete
with CIS women in the women's Athletics
can you
make this case and can you still man the
case against it I think in your
community there's a lot of trans folks
who love you and there's a lot who hate
you yeah and so if you can walk the
tightrope of this conversation to try to
steam on both sides one of the
argumentative strategies I say is that
like any time you have a conversation
you should be able to argue both sides
better than anybody else you know so um
for the for the my side the genuine
belief side
um it feels like overwhelmingly all of
the data is showing that trans mostly
trans women uh even after I think three
years on some sort of like HRT or you
know estrogen uh stuff they're still
maintaining these advantages from their
male puberty over cisgender women and if
that is the case if we are going to draw
these distinctions around our Sports
between women and men it feels unfair to
have a category inside the women's
sports that are maintaining advantages
that are coming from a male puberty
regardless of the amount of time they've
spent on a hormone replacement therapy
so that would be my argument on that
side so it's unfair from a performance
enhancement aspect so the same way we've
been
performance performance enhancing drugs
that involve increasing of testosterone
in that same way would be unfair
essentially yeah so what's the case uh
against the key yeah so the case in
favor of them competing together is that
realistically there's not going to be a
transports category uh realistically
trans women aren't going to be
competitive with CIS men because they've
gone through these huge uh you know like
hormone changes by the medication
they're taking
and that when we look at how sports are
kind of done anyway there's a whole
bunch of biological differences between
people within sports categories that are
determining their placement in the
professional world so for instance
um somebody like me is probably never
going to go far in the NBA because I'm
not tall enough I think the average
height in the NBA don't doubt yourselves
don't doubt myself yeah I want to say
like six six or something they're huge
people
um or you know you look at like Michael
Phelps as a classic example of a guy
whose torso is like so long his body is
built for swimming and I think there are
some trans people that will look at that
or somebody advocating for this position
they'll look at them they'll go okay
realistically the way that Michael
Phelps body processes lactic acid the
shape physiologically of his body is
going to put him in a level of
competition that so many men are never
going to reach just because of biology
how is it fair that you can have these
biological outliers competing in these
categories but then when we come to like
sports categories with translucentous
women you're going to take trans women
and say that they can't compete against
women can't you also just say that they
have some level of biological difference
there like is it really going to be that
great of a difference than what Michael
Phelps has versus the average swimmer or
an NBA player has versus like the
average height male